bonsoir madame merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france donc un ministre
par intérim que reçoit aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron elle rappelle l'accord
signé sous l'égide de la russie
il y a plusieurs mois à laquelle la
france n'a pas eu son mot à dire
on peut s'interroger sur cette porte est
aujourd'hui de 7 heures rencontre entre
les deux dirigeants
eh bien écoutez oui c'était c'est assez
étonnant mais même en même temps il faut
il faut savoir que comme monsieur
pashinian du temps est en campagne
électorale
actuellement puisqu'il a démissionné il
a démissionné pour essayer de faire
réélire à nouveau aux élections lors de
ces élections le 20 juin
monsieur pashinian cherche trois choses
1 il est venu en france
évidemment pour chercher l'appui de la
france pour des raisons à la fois
économiques culturelles et ça a été dit
dans votre votre reportage
évidemment pour essayer d'organiser le
retour des réfugiés des des prisonniers
de guerre qui sont nombreux et qui pose
dès qu'il pose un vrai problème dans les
négociations il est là également on pour
faire contrepoids à l'influencé russe
puisque l'opposition à 1 école pashinian
lui reproche beaucoup d'avoir
pratiquement tous et des eaux russes
enfin en tout cas d'avoir cédé trop une
trop grande proportion des territoires
aux azerbaïdjanais est bon donc
il a besoin de se refaire je dirais une
virginité par rapport à contrepoids à
vrai contrepoids par rapport à l'
influence russe
et puis troisièmement à cause de ces
regains de tension qui ont lieu comme ça
a été expliqué également dans notre
reportage
parce que ces tensions sont tout à fait
inquiétant t il ya quand même six
arméniens qui ont été kidnappés par par
les azerbaïdjanaises les caves à l
azerbaïdjan nadine ou non c'est pas vrai
enfin les les deux camps les deux camps
se renvoient la balle et pour les la
russie a donné l'impression de pas trop
de pas trop vouloir se mouiller bon
visiblement ils ont quand même envoyé le
fsb a quand même finalement envoyé des
troupes sur place donc si vous voulez
c'est quand même très inquiétant parce
que tout le monde a eu très peur lors de
l'ordre du conflit à propos du haut
karabakh et maintenant on est à nouveau
dans une tension très forte
à propos de frontières qui ne sont pas
très claires qui ne sont pas très bien
défini tout ça est flou donc je pense
que c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles pour lesquels pashinian nikol
pashinian via faire sa tournée auprès du
président macron et et auprès des
européens et c'est vrai et c'est vrai
que la france a des très bonnes
relations avec l'azerbaïdjan et avait
toujours depuis toujours de très bonnes
relations avec avec l'arménie est donc
et c'est vrai que la france a été très
silencieuse pendant se confier parce que
le silencieux parce que il était il
était vraiment dans les dirai à pied
devant peut-être à pied d'un dans chaque
camp alors la forme et joie qui dit
qu'elle fera tout pour je cite obtenir
la désescalade et le rétablissement du
dialogue entre bakou et erevan dans les
faits concrètement que va faire emmanuel
macron parce que encore une fois la
france pas fait grand chose par la force
des choses quand il ya eu ce conflit
qu'est ce qu'elle peut faire maintenant
pour établir ce dialogue d'écouté très
franchement je ne crois pas qu'elle
puisse vraiment faire grand chose
actuellement je pense que c'est ce sont
les russes qui est un petit peu le qui
tire à peu qui tire les ficelles et
qu'ils ont et qu'ils sont qui sont dans
le jeu dans le jeu franchement je ne
sais tu as c'est assez compliqué et
alors ce que peut faire est ce que peut
faire la france c'est les troupes où ils
ont demandé le retour des troupes de
l'ol c'est eux
l'organisation de sécurité de
coopération européenne et donc c'est un
appel que nikol pashinian faire la bce
donc ils vont demander que les troupes à
nouveau que les troupes viennent
viennent sur le terrain pour saper
reposer donc ça peut être une des choses
effectivement que même l macro enfin que
la france peut que pousser la france et
l'europe peuvent pousser pour le raid
manille
m l'implication française qui veut
contribuer sur le plan humanitaire avec
cette aide exceptionnelle accordée par
paris au comité international de la
croix rouge
c'est suffisant écouter de toute façon c
c'est toujours très important d'apporter
de l'aide humanitaire donc ça on peut
rien dire mais j'ai vu non je ne pense
pas que ce sera suffisant il va falloir
quelque chose de plus politique
obligatoirement mais merci on est bien
on encore une fois on oui je vous en
prie la journée ça mais encore une fois
je dis on en revient au rôle au rôle de
des russes qui qui qui joue un jeu très
très très malin dans toute cette affaire
en s'appliquant pas trop en laissant bon
mais voilà mais je pensais que mel et me
collent pas chagnon il ya fait signer
cet accord de paix tout de même on le
rappelle alors qu'elle avait un conflit
meurtrier sur le terrain c'est un
conflit qui peut rappeler que c'est un
conflit qui a fait 6000 membres
c'est quand même c'est quand même énorme
et c'est vrai que les russes ont en fait
on organisait si je puis dire le cessez
le feu et je crois que non on a beaucoup
reproché à nikol pashinian d'avoir
accepté ça puisque puisque les arméniens
ont perdu quelques glacis de territoire
autour du haut karabakh et ils ont perdu
la ville de souche à de choucha donc ce
qui est quand même ce qui est quand même
un revers si je puis dire pour les
arméniens et comme la france ne disait
rien à l'époque n'est pas intervenu n'a
rien dit bon voilà on essaye dans les
parties dans une espèce de 2,2 comme on
dit on va essayer de remettre ça sur la
table à nouveau
merci en tout cas patricia lalonde vice
président du groupe de réflexion géo
pragma chercheuse elipson nous avoir
apporté votre analyse sur cette
rencontre aujourd'hui merci à vous